[Music]
oh good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy friday at the end
of a long week
take three steps back if you had to sum
up this moment in our history what would
you call it
maybe the age of fraud we're living in a
time when the most powerful people in
the world
masquerade as the least powerful a time
when billionaires pose as helpless
victims
don't criticize bill gates a time when a
woman who
literally identifies as the duchess of
sussex
from canoga park tells oprah that she's
oppressed
and then oprah nods in empathy because
oprah's oppressed too
in a moment like this one it's probably
not too surprising that alexandria
ocasio-cortez feels deeply sorry for
herself
qazia cortez was elected to congress a
few years ago at the age of 28 she beat
a long-time
incumbent in a race that nobody thought
she could win her previous job famously
had been waiting tables and tending bar
at a taco place
in union square now people made fun of
that but we haven't
say what you will about ocasio-cortez's
views that is a legitimately impressive
achievement
if your daughter did it you'd be proud
honestly
but ocasio-cortez doesn't seem proud she
seems aggrieved
with every passing year as her fame and
power grows she seems angrier and more
brittle
within a month of arriving in washington
ocasio-cortez had amassed a larger
social media presence than
any member of congress in the first
month as of today she's got 12.6
million twitter followers that's nearly
twice as many as nancy pelosi has and
pelosi's been doing this for half a
century
so okazi cortez is one of the largest
political megaphones
on earth but she wants more than that
she now insists that not only should she
be able to speak totally unfiltered to
millions of people at once
but that nobody should be allowed to
disagree with what she says
in february her office sent a mass email
to supporters asking them to report
anyone who criticizes her to the tech
monopolies
for punishment quote scan your social
media to find posts with misleading
information
the email read use the built-in report
feature to flag them for
moderators well what is this it's pretty
straightforward
really here you have one of the most
powerful politicians in america
using the most powerful companies in the
world to censor her political opponents
that sounds like authoritarianism and in
fact if it was happening in say ghana
that's exactly what you'd call it but
since it's happening here in 2021 we
don't call it that we don't even notice
it
alexandria ocasio-cortez isn't a power
mad demagogue no no
she's a vulnerable young woman just
trying to protect herself from assault
to disagree with her is to injure her
when the left-wing podcaster jimmy dore
whom we're going to speak to in a moment
pushed ocasio-cortez to fight for a
higher minimum wage
she accused him of a crime that's
violence she wrote
so how do you protect yourself from
violence well you use
armed guards and she has last week
ocasio-cortez sat for an
interview on the middle east at the age
of 31 she is a much sought-after voice
on every possible topic from
economics to the way society is designed
to the details of complex foreign policy
questions
during this interview which was streamed
online she was asked
how do you bring peace between the
palestinians and the israelis
here's what she said you know
earlier just now you and i were we're
talking about the what
and the how and i think that when we
talk about
establishing peace um centering people's
humanities protecting people's rights
it's it's not just about the what
and that the end goal which often gets a
lot of focus
um but i actually think it's much more
about the how and the way that we are
coming together and how we are
how we interpret that what and how we
act uh
in you know the actions that we take to
get to that one
we value um jewish
and and rather we value israeli um
uh uh we value
the the safety and and the human rights
of israelis
we value the safety and the human rights
of palestinians
it went on like this we could play the
whole thing but you get the idea
centering people's humanity protecting
people's rights blah blah blah blah blah
it was vapor now if you were her mom
or her college roommate or a close
friend you might give her a pass for
what you just thought
it's pretty brave of her to weigh in on
a subject she knows nothing about you
might think to yourself
that's the charitable view of that video
but if you were a sincere progressive
and you were watching from
home hoping to be led by a leader you
would be deeply disappointed by that
performance
this is alexandria ocasio-cortez after
all lioness of the left
so where was her full-throated defense
of the palestinians
of their rights where was truth to power
that was ryan wentz's reaction wence is
a man of the left he's an anti-war
activist in california he watched and he
wasn't impressed and he said so
on twitter wence wrote this quote her
response was incredibly underwhelming
to say the least end quote that's what
he wrote
a week later the police showed up at his
house
two plainclothes officers from the
california highway patrol arrived
calling his name they explained they'd
been sent by the capitol police in
washington to respond to a threat
against a sitting member of congress
but whence hadn't threatened alexandria
casual cortes he hadn't threatened to
anyone
he'd merely disapproved of her opinions
but the police seemed
unconvinced as he explained in an
interview with the gray zone quote
they just wouldn't back down from this
accusation that i threatened to kill her
but here's the spookiest part ryan wenz
hadn't included
any personal information in his social
media profile
and yet the police knew his name and
they knew exactly where he lived
how did they find him it seems likely
that
twitter turned ryan wentz into
authorities
on behalf of their friend alexandria
ocasio-cortez
it's hard to believe this is happening
in america but it is
the california highway patrol confirmed
it today
the capitol police told us they referred
wence's name because he was mentioned in
a threatening message
they denied that ocasio-cortez requested
an investigation
for her part ocasio-cortez also denied
direct involvement in any of it
but she didn't seem especially upset
that it happened
she certainly didn't launch into an
impassioned speech about civil liberties
like a
liberal might do but then why would she
do that
threatening people for daring to
criticize the powerful
is normal now and that's a trend that's
accelerated dramatically since january 6
the day the hunt for domestic extremists
began
even at the time we noticed that no one
was defining those terms very clearly
what exactly is an extremist how is that
different from someone who disagrees
with the people in charge
those people are domestic terrorists
we're told they must be put down by
force the war on terror has moved
stateside extremists have breached
our walls they are inside our country
and in response we must hunt them down
none of these
newly energized and highly empowered
extremist hunters
have told us exactly what an extremist
is
so we're left to guess we're left to
look around nervously to see if we can
spot one
hoping against hope the whole time
they're not talking about us
are they
so what is an extremist a lot of people
assume that an extremist must be someone
who voted for donald trump or who
reads forbidden websites
no it turns out an extremist is anyone
who disagrees with alexandria casio
cortez
from the right or from the left